let's get back to the news because this
story
got me so fired up it really did
no jokes actually this is serious this
past week scotland became the very first
country
to make pads and tampons free for anyone
who needs them
by the way anyone how about women how
about that yeah
finally a study said that the average
woman spends over six thousand dollars
on menstrual products in their lifetime
or more if you have a heavy flow so
listen to this
this one just got the feminist and me
truly riled up and i'll go as far as to
say this is the ultimate ruffle
my feathers i think this shouldn't be a
first it should be the last
the last time we shouldn't support the
women who bring us into the world
preach drew barrymore
you think about this though but i mean
like so countries
they're providing it for them do they do
this and like can you just go to the
store and pick it up
how do they do it how do they hand it
out to everybody and how do we follow
suit
um that is a very good question and i
feel stupid for not having a retort but
i'm going to find out
and feel stupid i no because that's true
what is the functionality of
it but i just think this is should be a
standard norm in our society i remember
you used to have to go and do the
quarter
and the thing i just it's it's the women
that's how we get into this planet and i
feel like
we should have their backs in this and
it's a necessity i can't tell you how
many times i've been out with my
girlfriends when they're like oh no oh
no i don't have a pet i'm like don't
look at me girl i don't know how to help
you
but now thank you thank you scotland and
america catch up
yes every country every country in this
planet
have women's backs amen all right ross
did you see this quarantine meme
okay i absolutely love it and it's a big
thanks to natalie sher for bringing it
back into the world
it's originally from the wall street
journal a cat and a dog wrote
dueling op-eds about lockdown and the
cats wanted their owners
to get back to work and the dogs wanted
them to stay home forever
this is so true i have to i have three
dogs and like quarantine has been their
favorite time because i'm around
constantly i know and i've never had a
cat because i'm scared of them a little
bit because
my when i was a kid my neighbor would
have me feed it and that cat was a jerk
all right
and so i i'm still i'm like hesitant are
you a cat person dog person
i'm i have uh every animal under the sun
yeah i run a vet clinic at my house
basically
i should um okay ross tell me this story
quickly because okay
everyone knows we know drake right we i
think everyone has a crush on drake well
drake everyone
actor and now he's announced he wants to
play barack obama in a movie
and apparently the love is mutual drew
yes uh-huh vulture reports that obama
said he'd
really like champagne poppy to play him
in a biopic someday
and i honestly i could see it happen
right drake could
he could be great as obama well i you
need someone
that's extremely likable and drake
i mean anything drake does i think we're
all just in favor of
if somebody had a biopic of you who
would play you wrong you know i
i thought long and hard about it and the
only person i could think of was um
nathan lane but nathan lane in the bird
cage
remember him oh you do madonna madonna
but you keep it all inside all right
here's who would play me
it's marty feldman ladies and gentlemen
there we go